today's classic interview is with an
individual who went by the name Jackie
Keaton when we interviewed him and it
relates to net neutrality this was an
interview with a former Time Warner
Cable representative you know how cable
companies Internet companies are known
for like the worst customer service I
think it's car dealerships ISPs and
Airlines or something that are always
some of the worst rated in terms of
customer service
well we interviewed a former Time Warner
Cable rep who told us about all of the
tactics that they would use to
continually raise your bill rather than
lower it and it's an interview that
relates to net neutrality not in so far
as customer service reps actually
connect to Internet freedom but whenever
we hear these ISPs tell us we would
never do anything to just try to get
more money out of everybody like
creating internet slow lanes and fast
lanes you need only look at their sales
and retention practices as outlined to
us by Jackie Keaton back in October of
2014 to realize the second that these
companies are allowed to do internet
fast lanes and slow lanes they are going
to do them let's check out my interview
with Jackie Keaton I'm joined today by a
former Time Warner Cable retentions
agent we have agreed that he will go by
the name Jackie Keaton of course
protecting his identity is important to
both Jackie and to us so Jackie really
great to talk to you let's start at the
very beginning when you say a retentions
agent what does that mean you know
people are probably used to calling Time
Warner or Comcast when they have the the
very common problems people seem to have
with their bills and service what is
retention retention is actually a team
that's put in place to ensure that you
don't disconnect your services or they
don't downgrade your services if you
want to leave the company before you can
even start to get that rolling you have
to deal with the retention and this is
pretty common I mean in my experience
when I talk to my cell phone provider or
even a credit card that I want to cancel
rarely is whoever you initially talk to
actually empower to cancel that account
and in my experience and tell me if this
is good or bad advice when I'm calling
specifically because of a problem with
my bill or
want to negotiate a better rate I just
find I go directly to retentions whether
that's by saying to the phone tree that
I want to cancel my account or just
finding the retentions number is this a
good strategy in other words are
consumers going to save themselves some
time by going directly to a retentions
agent well it is true that there are
deals that are offered by retention that
aren't offered by any other departments
it isn't necessarily true that you'll
get to retention if you say you're going
to disconnect gotcha okay so we'll go
through the process with with Time
Warner so when you got a call what at
what point in the process were those
customers had they already spoken to a
regular customer service agent and had
indicated they want to cancel almost
always these people have been on the
line first sometimes upwards of two
hours okay so you get someone your phone
rings you take the call maybe they've
been on the phone for two hours are you
able to see how long total the person
has been on the phone you know sometimes
you get transferred around five six
seven times do you know what the
transfer history and total call length
has been absolutely not a lot of the
time another agent will just put them on
hold and say they'll be right back and
they'll be transferred to you
so when you greet them they're like what
I was just talking to someone else right
okay so let's talk a little bit about
the training process when you were
brought in what were you told was
ultimately the goal of what your job was
there to do what was there to accomplish
were you there to help people sort out
their bills were you there simply to
prevent people from canceling at all
costs how was your position described
the position is described as you're put
in place to help the customer realize
the value of their product so they won't
cancel gotcha and what tools and
techniques were the ones that you were
told you should be using to prevent
people from canceling de-escalation
mainly these people are usually pretty
upset when they get through to us
it's de-escalation restating the value
offering more services for a shorter
amount of time for a lower rate okay and
was there ever really a specific
situation where you were told listen if
someone calls
with this scenario you don't have to try
to upsell them or retain them if someone
calls because they're I don't know
they're the person who had the account
died for example redo you just say ok
we'll disconnect for you if they're
actually dead
they have to take a death certificate in
to the local payment center so we can't
actually do that over the line if
they're sick or something though you can
absolutely upsell and was that what you
were told to do so if someone calls in
and they say you know where my husband's
just really ill and either for financial
or other reasons we just don't really
want or need this anymore you were still
told in that case offer them more
expensive stuff right and how does that
work tell us a little bit about that
you'd say you first empathize say I'm I
can understand all that would be hard
listen is he going to be laid up for a
while what kind of things does he like
to watch on TV maybe we can add this NBA
Sports Pass or something like that and
we're there what would you say was was
the well let's let's I'll ask him two
ways
what was your success rate in terms of
the calls you got in getting people to
ultimately not cancel and was there an
expected or target success rate that was
established in other words what were the
metrics that were put in place the
metrics have put in place for how much
money you're actually saving a lot of
the time you can actually get a pay
raise by saving the company money by
preventing these people from
disconnecting but if you were to slip
below that rating you'd actually just go
back to the your initial flat pay rate
my actual rate of save I'm not sure what
I'd say probably it was pretty high
maybe like 70% so in other words that
means that of every 10 calls you could
save 70% or 7 of those people you could
prevent them from canceling right
because a lot of people they do call in
because they're frustrated about prices
if you can work with them a lot of the
time they do stay with the company just
if you're willing to work with them what
was the turnover rate in other words the
people that worked in this retention
department was it
a position in which people would stay
for a while where people just constantly
coming in and out and why were they
leaving constantly in and out everyone
was leaving just because of the actual
environment it's really hard to for
people to stay positive in a place where
everyone is so negative that you're
talking to on the phone yeah I mean it
would it would seem to me that it would
just become not only an incredibly
repetitive situation but also your your
like you said you're dealing with people
who are angry all the time I imagine
that that gets to you it absolutely did
yeah so I've been having as I've talked
about on the program an issue with Time
Warner here in New York City where I
think it's been 17 phone calls just
trying to get the price and package that
I was initially promised 13 months ago
when I moved to New York City it's
almost become kind of like a game where
I just wonder what are they going to
tell me next and every time I'll
reference the story up until that point
to kind of get us both on you know on
kind of equal footing is there any
accountability like does anyone care
what anyone else is said to me no no I'm
sorry the promises that are made what we
were supposed to never throw anyone
under the bus never say no they lied to
you what we're supposed to say is let me
look into that and I don't think that's
something we can actually do but let me
see what I can't do for you I've heard
that many many times so but and
ultimately often times I'll be told okay
listen David you know we we've got this
sorted out I apologize for the trouble
you've had what we set up is that your
next bill will be this amount and that's
what it will be for the next nine months
and then I get my next bill and it's $30
more in those cases was the last agent I
spoke to were they just straight-up
lying to me to get me off of the phone
did they believe that they had offered
that they had put in place the price I
was given and through some other
mechanism it didn't happen or what
exactly is going on behind the scenes
there it's funny you should ask that way
because it could be that they didn't do
it because there's no accountability it
could be that they try to do it but the
software wouldn't let it go through or
it could be that they tried to save you
money but the company actually wouldn't
approve the credit so sometimes somebody
might actually put in
say we are gonna give this customer this
credit and then at some point after we
get off the phone but before my next
bill bill comes in
someone who's higher up than the phone
agent said oh no no no we're not gonna
be doing this exactly and then they're
under no obligation or at least decide
they're not even gonna communicate that
to the customer I would guess no and
they don't tell the agency there so we
have no idea that's that's just
incredible
hey last thing I want to ask you about
you talked a little bit about how
depending on how many of these accounts
that people want to cancel how many of
them you're saving that there's kind of
like a variable pay or bonus structure
so how does that work is that a
significant proportion of someone's base
salary in other words can your salary
really change drastically based on how
many people you're convincing not to
cancel absolutely not
no at most it's a $2 thing and that goes
by every two weeks depending on how well
you're doing it's nothing that you could
strive for if you know what I mean
understood okay and then how about as
far as what tends to happen to everybody
which is you get one price for six
months and then it goes up and then it
goes up and that entire kind of the
billing creep that takes place what's
the best way to prevent that or at least
to to counteract it it would be to keep
in touch with them one thing that is the
reason that that's sort of justified in
the company anyway is because you don't
actually have a contract like these
other companies so you can call in and
adjust rates it's not I mean it's
obviously not the best practice to keep
changing the rates I'm not trying to
defend that but you are able to
negotiate with them all right so it
seems that that is with it's almost like
you just need to set a calendar reminder
every three months you should be calling
up to negotiate I can't I can't say
whether or not that's true all right
we've been speaking with Jackie Keaton
former Time Warner Cable retentions
agent Jackie thanks for being with us
absolutely thanks for having me David